Ngắm đốc tổ chức i tây thây dởi vì cái thân ho, đã có mặt tại thủ lâu kinh sà xà của cốc ngoài rất trụ công hồ,
để trực tiếp điều phối ứng phó với dịch Pé Bô La đang bùng phát tại đây.
Người đứng đồ về cái thân hoa cho biết tình hành dịch Pé Bô La được đánh giá là giết phức tạp.
Pé xuống đồ tình trạp dịch cư và thiếu nềm tin đang cạnh trở công tắc kìm xóa dịch bệnh.
Dù bùng phát Pé Bô La tại công hồ được cho là đã kiến hơn 2,5 gình.
Xin lộ các vị đã kiến hơn 2,5 gình.
Bà hơn một nghìn càng như nhé.
Bế kế bà đồ cũng nhấn mạnh. Nhu cầu cấp thiết về tăng tường tại trở của tế để tướng phó dịch bệnh.
Vì muốn lực hiện này mới chỉ đã ứng phóng một tình bà sau với Nhu cầu đã ra.
Mời đầy khoảng 1,5 tình tình bị ý tế và vật tư thiết yêu đã được bế kế bà đồ trình tới tình.
Y tuyên của tổng mà rất trụ công hồ.
Trong số đó có 2 nghiệm bộ xanh ý tế, giúp trình đoán các trình hợp nghiệm với Bô La đang hành hợp.